j'ai eu le géant du restaurant en fait
il est 8h du matin il dit qu'il y a des
familles qui prennent des petits
déjeuners que ça a pu choquer des
familles moi je moi je franchement je
comprends enfin tes familles qui
prennent des petits déjeuner oui il a il
lui dit que ça peut choqué une partie de
la clientèle et moi au-delà de ça enfin
les tenues et c'est vrai qu'il y a un
débat là-dessus mais moi c'est tout ce
que je déteste sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire que voilà vous arrivez vous
vous mettez à crier vous filmez la scène
en hurlant à la discrimination tout ça
pour gagner 3 abonnés sur Tik Tok je
suis désolé moi personnellement j'ai
rien contre vous mais je trouve ça
concernant
il y a tout à l'heure il y a il y a
Superman qui va arriver parce qu'en plus
elle a dit qu'elle vous connaissez donc
Gilles
qu'est-ce que vous répondez ça Polsky
Toutatice à ce qui vous a dit bah c'est
clairement la discrimination enfin je
comprends pas en quoi en fait le patron
c'est même pas les gaz qui l'a fait il
peut pas nous virer comme ça parce que
la seule raison pour laquelle il peut
virer quelqu'un c'est c'est pour motif
d'ordre public qui est là en quoi on
trouve leur public avec nos tenues c'est
pas choquant
quand vous êtes en train de créer la
discrimination c'est pas ça c'est la
discrimination c'est quand pour vous
refuse parce que vous êtes noir parce
que vous êtes homosexuel là vous avez
une tenue qui pardon et inapproprié pour
aller prendre un petit déjeuner je suis
désolé mais quand j'ai mangé des
croissants je m'habille pas comme ça et
c'est juste dégueulasse et franchement
c'est vrai et et et et et alors combien
même vous faites moi je me fais recaler
d'un restaurant j'ai pas mettre une
vidéo pour pleurnicher et hurler à la
discrimination c'est franchement il faut
il faut arrêter avec ces trucs là vous
voulez pas travailler plutôt que faire
des vidéos qui servent à rien
franchement
[Applaudissements]
c'est la police du costume teinté de
misogynie c'est de la discrimination
vous citiez qui les Noirs oui ils sont
refoulés et elles sont refoulées parce
qu'elles sont des femmes
c'est de la misogynie pure et simple
c'est de la misogynie Daniel avec la
même tenue
c'est parfaitement hors-la-loi il n'a
pas le droit j'étais dans des tenues
décentes elle voulait prendre un petit
déjeuner on les refoule
il a été très je suis désolé alors vous
c'est vrai que voilà
Toutatice mais là Paul Seka je suis
désolé la tenue elle est je pourrais la
mettre
de face
quand vous entendez ça vous dites c'est
ça continue la discrimination que vous
savez pas ce que le monsieur a déjà
avant quand il nous a dit il a commencé
à donner déjà des des excuses et après
qu'on nous a dit non mais dites-nous
clairement pourquoi vous ne refusez il a
dit vous avez des tenues de
stripteaseuses oui vous décolleté c'est
n'importe quoi on dirait des prostituées
ça veut dire que vous cautionnez tes
propos ça veut dire non mais moi c'est
pas la réaction en fait c'est vous savez
qu'en disant la tenue a arrêté de face
ça va arrêter non là je suis pas
d'accord avec vous là là sur la tenue de
de polka là la tenue Guillaume la tenue
là bah moi je comprends la réaction
après il peut y avoir
la tenue voilà sur la tenue je pense
qu'il serait arrivé habillé torse
et le problème c'est pas tant ça c'est
le fait de crier au scandale pour un oui
ou pour un nom et parce que le patron du
restaurant le résultat c'est qu'il se
fait insulter aujourd'hui toute la
journée et qu'il y a d'autres
restaurants
aussi et il y a des restaurants elles
sont insultés il y a des restaurants non
mais je cautionne pas ça non plus mais
il y a des restaurants malheureusement
il y a vraiment du racisme où il y a
vraiment de l'homophobie il y a vraiment
de la discrimination et il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui de crier au scandale pour
tout et n'importe quoi tout ce que vous
voulez faire c'est faire du buzz à deux
balles
c'est pas vrai
quand même